ah
[Música]
de acuerdo con información oficial en
mexico hasta el último corte en
septiembre se habían cometido más de 700
feminicidios en el país un delito con
tendencia al alza desde 2015 cuando hubo
411 la entidad con más denuncias por
femicidio es el estado de mexico seguido
por veracruz el caso más reciente que se
convirtió en noticia es el de la niña
sofía una menor de 12 años de edad que
fue secuestrada agredida sexualmente y
posteriormente asfixiada en zacatecas el
pasado 22 de noviembre pobladores del
municipio de fresnillo causaron
destrozos y prendieron fuego a la
alcaldía para exigir justicia por este
crimen por otra parte el gobierno
federal conmemora este día de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer con una disculpa pública que
ofrece a yesenia samudio por las fallas
en la investigación del feminicidio de
su hija maritxu en 2016 asimismo
distintas colectivas feministas
convocaron a una marcha para exigir que
cese la violencia de género
[Música]
en perú la violencia contra las mujeres
es otra pandemia según cifras oficiales
el 66 por ciento de mujeres mayores de
18 años ha sufrido violencia física o
psicológica mientras que el 58 por
ciento de mujeres entre 15 y 49 años
padeció algún tipo de violencia por
parte de su pareja en paralelo la
defensoría del pueblo revela que 4.500
mujeres niñas y adolescentes desde enero
a octubre fueron reportadas como
desaparecidas por su parte al ministerio
de la mujer y poblaciones vulnerables ha
reportado que en lo que va del 2020 se
han registrado 101 feminicidios 234
tentativas de feminicidios y 6 mil 893
casos de violencia sexual diversas
organizaciones sociales exigen al estado
peruano soluciones urgentes y un
protocolo efectivo que aborde casos de
violencia machista y desapariciones
forzadas por eso en la fecha se lanzan
campañas como no estás sola actuaremos
ahora que buscan prevenir los tipos de
violencia contra las mujeres y que el
gobierno y la sociedad acompañen
adecuadamente a las víctimas
[Música]
maría heredia es una mujer que he hecho
de 53 años que se constituye en la
víctima más reciente de la violencia
política en bolivia
ella es alcaldesa del municipio de sipe
sipe de cochabamba donde sus vecinos la
han retenido durante dos días y una
noche para obligarla a firmar un
contrato irregular con una empresa para
la dotación de alimentos al municipio
durante ese tiempo maría heredia no ha
tenido acceso a agua alimentos y ni
siquiera a medicinas o atención
hospitalaria pese a que ella está
enferma incluso cuando sus vecinos
trataban de subirla a un burro como un
método de humillación ella se ha
desvanecido y ha tenido que ser atendida
con oxígeno maría es una más de las
víctimas de violencia política en
bolivia donde actualmente se procesan
154 casos de este tipo en diferentes
instancias que además hay que decir la
mayoría quedan en la
impunidad y son casos que según acobol
que es la asociación de concejalas de
bolivia van en aumento día que pasa
[Música]
france24 punto